J'étais comme toi
vulnérable incertain effrayé par la mort
puis tout a changé il y a seulement 12
heures je n'ai rien fait je t'en supplie
s'il te plait on a glissé un paquet de
quelque chose de très spécial dans ton estomac
et tu vas le transporter  pour nous
respectons les règles de Sam personne ne se
blesse on dit que les humains n'utilisent que 10%
de notre capacité cérébrale mais et s'il
y avait un moyen d'accéder à 100% de notre
cerveau de
quoi pourrions-nous être capables oui
professeur Norman je viens de lire  toutes tes
recherches sur l'utilisation des capacités du cerveau
c'est un peu rudimentaire mais
tu es sur la bonne voie merci
[Musique]
je suis capable de faire des choses que je n'ai jamais faites
avant je ressens tout et je peux
contrôler les éléments autour  moi, nous devons
nous rencontrer croyez-moi, le produit chimique lui
permet de déverrouiller de nouvelles zones de notre
cerveau,
elle a des capacités,
ils ne peuvent pas tomber entre de mauvaises mains, il est
temps d'y aller, puis de rater le mouvement.
par  la minute
arrive quand elle atteint 100%
mais c'est la chef
hé hé non c'est une voiture de police